and maybe this is why or one of the
reasons why the green bay packers did
the unthinkable
they have drafted by all appearances the
heir to aaron rodgers in trading up
four spots to get utah state quarterback
jordan love at the bottom of the round i
don't know who they were trying to get
in front of because none of the teams in
between
but but somebody could have swooped in
from round two in one of those spots i
think they were concerned that maybe as
they wait for love to fall to them at 30
someone gets in at 27-28-29 either way
chris the stunner of all stunners last
night to me it was even more stunning
than the tuatanga viloa selection at
number five because
uh jordan love
coming in while aaron rodgers has made
it clear he wants to play into his 40s
he isn't doing that brett favre of
willard won't i retire that's why they
drafted aaron rodgers in 2005 in round
one because they didn't know when brett
favre was going to walk away rogers has
made the commitment i joked last night
on twitter i just wonder if they saw
that photo of aaron earlier this week
looking all old and grizzled and got
scared
and thought maybe we better get another
quarterback aaron looks like he's 50.
well i i i mean listen i don't even know
what to say about this i i'm
you know me mike i i was i'm a fan of
jordan love i like him you know i think
you know he has a ceiling and when he's
really on his game and looks good
he reminds me of aaron rodgers he has a
lot of the same mannerisms the way he
throws the football
there's a lot of similarities i get it
and i know there were some teams in
football like me who fell in love with
whoa man when this guy is on it can be
special now the problem is it's just all
over the place he is a project you know
i think he's very raw mentally and
physically right now wasn't taught a lot
of football at utah state he just
getting it done with pure ability and
there's inconsistencies with decision
making and even some of the accuracy and
throws but mike i mean if we took like
the top four quarterbacks and had a top
ten throws you know highlight reel
jordan loves gonna have like four of
them on that reel out of those
quarterbacks because there's some just
unreal plays but i just want to go with
green bay wait wait wait wait what are
we talking about aaron rodgers isn't
going anywhere for four to five years
we're in the era where the quarterback
can last forever
well i know you know and i just sit
there and go with green bay i want to go
man we traded up to get them i you know
like you i'm a little scared there but
maybe they were scared of new england or
the colts trading up i don't know
and then the other thing i'll say mike
is
man they need to address their defensive
line the 49ers are still running
nobody's tackled them yet from the nfc
championship game most are still going
this is one of the worst run defenses of
football are they going to get some big
people to help their team out so yeah
this pissed me off i don't know what
else to say they pissed me off i like
this kid jordan love but they've hurt my
aaron rodgers feelings and i don't like
it
and here's the thing
we all know by now that aaron rodgers
can be a little sensitive remember the
60 minutes piece from several years ago
when
they dared to point out that he's so
sensitive that he's sensitive about
being called sensitive and he called out
60 minutes for doing it and 60 minutes
took to social media to say you just
proved our point here's the thing he's
very cerebral he's very smart i think
that he thinks 10 moves ahead on the
chess board and now he sees that the
packers are thinking 10 moves ahead on
the chess board and this could eat at
him this could gnaw at him this could
make him
not happy in green bay i agree this
could be this could be the thing yeah we
we
they knew how to deal with brett favre
they wanted brett favre to finally go
away so they went to him in february and
said we need to know right now are you
playing in 2008 and they knew that if
they asked him then and there to give a
commitment or walk away in february he
would walk away and then they just had
to hope that he wouldn't come back and
he did they had to deal with it with
aaron it's a different psychology
drafting his successor may be all it
takes to just start that trail of
dominoes toward aaron eventually saying
you know what tom brady got to play
somewhere else peyton manning got to
play somewhere else brett favre got to
play somewhere else maybe i'd like to
play somewhere else so who knows who
knows
who knows where we will see aaron
rodgers two three four years from now
but now it's not about just when do the
packers want to go from aaron rodgers to
jordan love aaron rodgers is going to
start spinning in his mind
no doubt i want to break up with them
before they break up with me
no i mean i agree with you i mean it
almost puts the power in aaron rodgers
court a little bit with making this type
of move you know yeah he's going to be
motivated he's going to be pissed off
he might throw 38 touchdowns this year
and four interceptions and ask for
another 10 million dollars per year on
his contract or might be like you know
what i've had enough you got your guy
trade me let's move on i mean really i
just um you know again i like jordan
love he's a project
i just don't think we're close to the
end of the road with aaron rodgers yet
to me you know again
you know the new england patriots jack
drafted jimmy garoppolo because they saw
a slippage in brady's play and then he
picked it up and they said okay see you
jimmy you're out of here you know brett
favre you mentioned it there was the
threat of retiring
right now
i don't think you could find anybody in
football who would argue that aaron
rodgers is still one of the five best
quarterbacks in the league and that it's
not going to fall off anytime soon i
mean maybe he becomes number six next
year i don't know but he's still going
to be able to play at a very high level
to where i just sit here and go
you know are they ever going to get
anything out of this pick or that is
what's gonna come of it when it's all
said and done and that's gonna be you
know only only uh the future will tell
us the answers to that but yeah
definitely a little peculiar to me
this is gonna give us something to talk
about once we step into the void of no
offseason workouts but the last thing i
want to say for now and this goes back
to the new cba that was ratified by the
players last month they changed the
fifth year option now look
he's not he's not a top 10 guy so it
wouldn't have been a ridiculously high
price for jordan love the fifth year
anyway but the way they've done the
fifth year option if you sit him for
three years and he never plays you are
going to have the lowest possible price
to keep him for that fifth year so you
know this may be just a matter of having
an insurance policy behind aaron rodgers
let him develop slowly if he doesn't
play the first two or three years so be
it he'll be cheaper in year five we
control him for five seasons and then we
decide what we're going to do long-term
assuming that at some point between now
and then aaron rodgers doesn't show up
and say i want out because i'm telling
you this is going to work on him it is
going to prey on him and is going to
poison eventually his relationship with
the team and he is going to want out
write it down i'm tell i'm not trying to
create drama here because yeah no i
don't i just i i think they're just
connecting dots of things we've seen
over the years everything we've seen for
the past 15 years he follows the
personality type that this is going to
piss him off and it is going to wear on
him and it is going to make him
just think that they don't want him so
before they make it official that we
don't want you he's going to say this
see you later this is totally to me
i'm going to blank on his name when john
elway was the quarterback of the broncos
and they drafted
tommy this is this is this all over
again that's to me what it is now jordan
love has a higher ceiling than tommy
maddox jordan love can be a superstar
so you know there there is some
something here to that but
again i think it's going to be just like
denver it's going to be oh aaron rodgers
is still here we're gonna have to get
rid of tommy maddox and he's enough to
go play somewhere else and man we wasted
the 26th pick of the draft on somebody
that we never let play a down here on
our football team that's what i worry
about ultimately with this big
interesting days in green bay to come
and uh thank you packers for giving us
something that we will be talking about
for
months to come and they knew it they
knew that that's how much they liked
jordan love they don't walk into this
blindly they knew
that they were lighting this fuse
and they did it anyway
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports